FDP leader Philip Posner came out  fighting taking on the opposition's  plans to raise taxes yet again it's a  message that resonates with the party  faithful who gave him a round of  applause the FDP hopes the promise of no  more taxes will be popular come election  time the fiscal conservatives are  sticking to party principles heading  into this year's federal elections  national polls currently place them  below the 5 percent margin needed for a  representation in Parliament but lo  Smith keynote address had the desired  effect rallying the rank-and-file green  morality police and the FDP is busy  putting together this year's party  platform the party is sticking to  popular party principles like low taxes  and less regulation  I know blue Donna is the party's  leadership candidate he delivers his  campaign address on Sunday